WEEKLY OR MONTHLY OCCURRENCE AT
EVERY LIBERAL STATE AND CITY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY?
MY NEXT GUEST IS NOW BOWING TO
FIX THE BROKEN SYSTEM AT LEAST
IN NEW YORK AND BY THE WAY IS
THE BLUE AS NEW YORK IS FROM OR
WHAT HAPPEN WITH THE
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA
REMEMBER HOW CLOSE THAT RACE WAS
A NEW JERSEY AND NOBODY WAS
PAYING ATTENTION TO IT HAVE WE?
PROBABLY MURPHY WOULD'VE BEEN
THROWN OUT.
SO YES THIS IS A REAL RACE IN
YOUR MARKET LOOKS LIKE.
YOU VERY QUICKLY WENT RIGHT FOR
THE WRIST AS A MARTIAL ARTIST I
RESPECT YOUR QUICK RESPONSE ON
IT I WISH YOU WOULD USE THE
LEFT-HAND BUT THE FACT THAT YOU
ACTED THAT QUICKLY PREVENTED HIM
FROM SEEKING THAT NIGHT HE
COULD'VE FIGURE CAROTID ARTERY
WE MIGHT NOT BE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION TODAY YOU DID A GREAT
JOB I CONGRATULATE YOU.
>> THANK YOU SEAN I GIVE A LOT
OF CREDIT TO THE 7-8-9 PEOPLE
INSTANTLY WITHIN A FEW MOMENTS
CAME TO THE STAGE AND TACKLED
THIS ATTACKER LAW ENFORCEMENT
WAS THERE JUST A COUPLE MINUTES
LATER AND THEY ARREST THE GUY A
LOT WENT RIGHT IN THE RESPONSE
WHEN I SAW HIM LUNCH AT ME WITH
THAT WEAPON IN HIS HANDS HE WAS
GOING TOWARDS MY NECK AREA I'D
SEDUCTIVELY WENT OUT TO GRAB THE
REST AND I JUST NEEDED TO HOLD
IT FOR A FEW MOMENTS UNTIL A
GROUP CAME IN.
>> Hannity: WERE LOOKING AT IT
FROM DIFFERENT ANGLES AS WE
SPEAK HERE.
THIS WAS AN ASSASSINATION
ATTEMPT.
LAST NIGHT YOU PREDICTED HE
WOULD BE LET OUT LET OUT WITH NO
BAIL AND SURE ENOUGH A GUY WHO
WAS TRYING TO ASSASSINATE A
SITTING CONGRESSMAN THE
CANDIDATE'S LET OUT ON HIS OWN
RECOGNIZANCE NO BAIL WHATSOEVER
NOW THIS IS INSANITY I SO WE CAN
TRY AGAIN?
>> YOU HAVE A PERSON THAT SAYING
YOU'RE DONE YOU REPEATED THAT
HE'S LAUNCHING AT ME WITH THIS
WEAPON BUT THE TWO DAGGERS
COMING OUT OF IT SIMILAR TO
BRASS KNUCKLES HE IS CHARGED
WITH A VIOLENT FELONY AND HE IS
INSTANTLY RELEASED BACK ON THE
STREET BECAUSE OF NEW YORK'S
BAIL LAWS I SAW IT COMING I WISH
IT WASN'T THIS WAY AND WE KEEP
HEARING TO MANY OF THESE STORIES
AS YOU WERE JUST POINTING OUT
SOME OF THE DECISIONS WITH THE
JOSE IS ANOTHER STORY THAT CAME
OUT A COUPLE WEEKS AGO WERE TO
MEXICAN CARTEL DRUG SMUGGLERS
GOT TOP WITH $1.2 MILLION WORTH
OF CRYSTAL METH AND THEN THEY
WERE INSTANTLY RELEASED BACK
ONTO THE STREETS.
AS THE ARGUMENTS THAT ADVOCATES
SAY THAT YOU SHOULDN'T BE STUCK
BEHIND BARS A LOW-LEVEL OFFENSE
YOU'RE NOT A DANGER A FLIGHT
RISK OF A CLEAN RECORD SHOULD BE
STUCK BECAUSE YOU CAN'T AFFORD
ANY AMOUNT OF BAIL YOU HAVE NO
MONEY.
I GET THAT BUT I WOULD SAY THAT
IF YOU HAVE $1.2 MILLION OF
CRYSTAL METH AND YOUR HAVE ANY
MONEY TO PAY YOUR BILLS, BAIL
THAT'S ON YOU.
YOUR BAD BUSINESSMAN A BAD
DEALER AND A BAG CRIMINAL.
WERE SEEING THE STORIES THAT AT
SOME OF THESE CASES LIKE EARLIER
TODAY I WAS IN SYRACUSE,
NEW YORK, THERE WAS A
93-YEAR-OLD WHO WAS MURDERED BY
SOMEBODY RELEASED ON CASHLESS
BAIL.
THERE IS MORE JUST DATA THESE
ARE STORIES, THESE ARE REAL
LIVES IT'S BEEN A FAILURE AND
THEY NEED TO BE REPEALED IN
NEW YORK.
>> Hannity: I'D LIKE FOR YOU
TO EAT EXPLAIN THIS IN EMAIL
WENT OUT BY THE GOVERNOR'S
CAMPAIGN.
GIVING OUT ALL THE INFORMATION
ABOUT EVERY UPCOMING CAMPAIGN
EVENT THIS IS BEFORE YESTERDAY.
INCLUDING THE DATES, TIMES AND
WHEN THE EVENTS ARE SCHEDULED TO
BEGIN.
NOW IN LIGHT OF WHAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING WITH SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES IN LIGHT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE HAVE IN THE
COUNTRY.
YOU THINK THAT MAYBE SHE
WOULD'VE LEARNED SOMETHING FROM
YESTERDAY MY UNDERSTANDING IS
MORE PEOPLE TO FALL YOU AGAIN
TODAY AFTER THE ASSASSINATION
ATTEMPT ON YOUR LIFE LAST NIGHT.
AS I WAS GOING THROUGH TODAY'S
SCHEDULE WITH OBVIOUSLY RAMPED
UP SECURITY WHICH WILL BE RAMPED
UP FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE
CAMPAIGN I WAS TRAVELING FROM
THE COUNTY WHERE SYRACUSE IS
LOCATED UP TO WATERTOWN THAT'S
WHERE IT IS IN JEFFERSON COUNTY
AS WERE DRIVING UP THIS BOX
TRUCK WITH MY FACE AND NAME ON
IT CRITICIZING ME AS FOLLOWED US
UP TO THE NEXT RALLY SO WE HAVE
RALLIES TOMORROW ALL DAY WE HAVE
RALLIES ON SUNDAY ALL DAY I
WOULD SUGGEST IF I WAS KATHY AND
HER CAMPAIGN THAT I WOULD HAVE
THIS BOX TRUCK SITTING ON SOME
DRIVEWAY WHO WAS EVER IN POPOUT
IT'S PRETTY BAD TASTE BAD
JUDGMENT HAVE IT RIGHT BACK ON
THE ROAD FOLLOWING SALSA GROUND
THE NEXT DAY.
TO GO WORSE THAN BAD JUDGMENT IS
DANGEROUS IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED LAST NIGHT LOOK WITH
THE CAMPAIGN DID AS WE BEEN
DOXXING SUPREME COURT JUSTICES
AND OUR CHILDREN WHEN THEY GO TO
SCHOOL AND THE CHURCH IS THAT
THEY ATTEND AND THE TIMES THEY
ATTEND CHURCH OR GIVING OUT THE
LOCATION WHERE YOU ARE EVERY
SECOND OF EVERY MINUTE OF EVERY
DAY IN LIGHT OF LAST NIGHT WAS A
BAD IDEA AND THAT SHE FOLLOWS
YOU AGAIN TODAY SHE IS SENDING
MORE PEOPLE OUT THAT SHE NOT SEE
WHAT HAPPENED LAST NIGHT?
DOES SHE EVER TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THESE NO
BAND LOSS?
IF SHE NOT UNDERSTAND THE DANGER
OF RELEASING VIOLENT CRIMINALS
THE GUY WHO ATTACKED YOU LAST
NIGHT COULD HAVE KILLED YOU IF
YOU LOOK AT THE VIDEO CLOSELY
AND AGAIN I LOOK AT YOUR HAND HE
WAS GONE RIGHT UP HERE FOR YOUR
NECK.
I HAVE TO GIVE YOU CREDIT
BECAUSE WITH A LOT OF STRENGTH
HE GRABBED HIS WRIST AND YOU PUT
HIM DOWN LONG ENOUGH TO GET THE
ASSISTANCE THAT CAME IN BEHIND
YOU.
THAT COULD'VE ENDED VERY BADLY
LAST NIGHT.
>> SHE HAS BEEN ASKED ABOUT THE
NEED TO OVERHAUL BAIL HER ANSWER
WAS WHEN THE MEDIA WAS ASKING
THAT SHE NEEDS MORE DATA.
NOW WE KNOW THAT THERE IS DATA I
WOULD ENCOURAGE HER TO COUNT UP
THE PRESS CLIPPINGS OF THE
AMOUNT OF CASHLESS BAIL STORIES
AND THAT NUMBER CAN BE THE DATA
MEANWHILE JUST A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO AFTER THE SUPREME COURT
ISSUED THE CORRECT DECISION YOUR
CONCEIT CARRY LAWS A LOOK LATER
SHE PASSED ALL SORTS OF NEW LAWS
THAN TRAVELING ALL
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS TRAMPLED
OVER SEGMENT RIGHTS EVEN MORE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL THAN WHAT
SUPREME COURT HAD JUST RULED
UPON.
THE MEDIA ASKED HER WILL DO YOU
HAVE ANY DATA TO BACK UP GOING
AFTER THESE CONCEALED CARRY
PERMIT HOLDERS THAT THEY ARE THE
ONES CAUSING THE PROBLEM AND SHE
SAYS THAT SHE DOESN'T NEED DATA
THAT SHE IS IN THE GOVERNOR
WHO'S ASKED ABOUT ALVIN BRAGG,
SOME SLACK HE'S DOING HIS JOB HE
JUST GOT THERE.
I SAY THAT ON JANUARY 1ST MY
FIRST DAY AS GOVERNOR IS NOT
JUST THE CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY IS MY CONSTITUTIONAL
DUTY TO REMOVE ALVIN BRAGG IS MY
FIRST ACT AS GOVERNOR WHEN SHE
WAS ASKED JUST A LITTLE WHILE
AGO A FEW DAYS AGO ABOUT THE
JOSE CODY'S SHE SAYS THAT SHE'S
NOT TO GET INVOLVED IN IT ALL IS
UNDER BUSINESS I WOULD ARGUE
THAT IF THERE WAS 1 OF 19000000
NEW YORKERS HAVE A DUTY
RESPONSIBILITY SPEAK UP WE HAVE
AT THE AGE WHEN THE WRONG THING
IS THE GOVERNOR BY THE
CONSTITUTION WE DO NOT HAVE A
RECALL IN THE STATE'S THERE'S A
WHOLE LOT OF BAD JUDGMENT
COLLECTIVELY AND SHE REALLY
NEEDS TO GO THIS IS ROCK-BOTTOM
WAY TO ROCK-BOTTOM SHE HAS TO
GO.
>> Hannity: I HAVE THE HONOR
OF MEETING YOUR WIFE IN A LOVELY
FAMILY THANK GOD YOU'RE OKAY
GREAT JOB GET AN AMAZING JOB
STOPPING THE SKY RELIEVE COMING
TILL LAST NIGHT CONGRESSMAN WERE
GLAD YOU'RE OKAY WE SHOOT YOUR
WELL THIS IS A WINNABLE RACE OF
EVERYONE IN NEW YORK IS PAYING
ATTENTION BECAUSE YOU CAN SET A